this is America and this is me in
America specifically San Diego in
California I've come here to San Diego
for comic-con comic-con if you don't
know what comic-con is it's basically
the biggest fan convention for nerdy
cool things in the world ever I've been
here for a day so far and I've tried to
do some filming for this already bloats
it's been a bit overwhelming and I've
been very jet-lagged and I'm still
jet-lagged I mean I wake up at like 4
o'clock this morning I am awake so that
is a good thing I'm excited and I'm
feeling energy flowing through my body
I'm doing my best to get into the
American spirit of everything so I had
some Oreos for my breakfast and I'm here
in San Diego with someone that a few of
you might know she's called
communitychannel and you don't know who
natalie is I would definitely recommend
checking her out because she is a
top-class vlogger she's brilliant I'm
not here to talk about her I'm here to
talk about comic-con call me corn
don't know why did that when I wait to
comic-con yesterday I was very much
overwhelmed by the whole thing comic-con
is big it is massive and there are a lot
of people here just as a general rule
being an internet nerd I'm not a massive
fan of crowds of people crowds are
always a bit overwhelming but they were
crowds of nerds like me so it wasn't too
bad in the morning I went to Disney's 3d
panel I got to see some exclusive 3d
footage of Christmas Carol Tron and
Alice in Wonderland Christmas Carol is
being done by the same person that did
Polar Express this one looks
particularly good because it follows the
book very very closely and the book is
very very scary so the movie is set to
be very very scary as well also
something that's interesting is the fact
that Jim Carrey plays seven different
characters in the film which is a bit
mad and looks very good also so Alice in
Wonderland that was really good as well
Alice in Wonderland is Tim Burton's new
film is actually six times in the past
all those dressed as Sailor Moon your
people
the guy who was running the panel got so
excited about Alice in Wonderland that
the trailer that they showed he made
them show it two more times just because
he loved it so much and it does look
really really good there was one point
because timber and was there and Tim
Burton was asking some questions and
being Tim Burton and being cool and
there was one point where he was like I
brought a friend with me and then Johnny
Depp came out and Johnny Depp was like
whoa I'm dirty depth obviously and
everyone stood up when they were like
whoa dirty depth and then Johnny Depp
went like this hi I left uh-huh I don't
know why we all got excited but Tony
that was there
Johnny Johnny Depp Johnny Depp and
finally Tron looks pretty freaking
awesome I don't know how many of you
know the original Tron film which was
done I think it was back in the 80s it
was the first film to ever use 3d
modeling animation and they're making a
sequel to it you know 20 years on
whatever it is and it looks very cool I
mean I'm a fan of the old film so I'm
especially interested in this so I'm
excited to see that film which is coming
out and I think 2010 probably I don't
know today I'm going to have a look at
more Disney stuff I should probably
mention I am here because Disney they
gave me this press pass and everything
but what Disney have said to me is we
are going to show you our stuff and then
you can say whatever you want about it
so they're just letting me be honest
about everything I see which is really
really cool and also they say you know I
could talk about whatever I want I don't
have to just talk about Disney but it
just so happens at the moment that the
only thing I've really seen is Disney
related things but today I will be doing
some Disney things and some other things
so expects that later you've just had
the almost imponderable joy of watching
Charlie is so cool like which makes you
like cool